dijon ne se trouve pas sur dark souls 3
j'arrête pas de jouer à ce jeu depuis
une semaine je vais décide enfin à faire
vidéo dessus pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas c'est un jeu voilà en
gros tu démontes vous c'est extrêmement
dur de le mec qui s'amplifie à mort et
là les amis nous arrivons au niveau d'un
boss on va affronter ensemble on va
vraiment décédé à quoi il ressemble
c'est le porte qui se ferme par fait au
feeling on perd là-bas écoute et
bienvenue sur deux ou trois un vrai
plaisir de vous présenter je voulais
absolument tout commence sur un boss
voilà juste pour qu'on en chine vient
gratuitement le tout à fait cette
analyse et les combos des rats des
monstres et des skins et regarder
matthew fox mois pour que moi c'est bon
j'ai vu tout va bien nous aura pas à
nice qui fait sa main voyons n'est pas
mal c'est comme ça que ça marche on
achemine large observé tu tapes
j'observais tu tapes on tape on estime
que la puissance jean pierre foucault
soit avec nous on a esquivé et la boue
ils me disent pas qu'ils à cielo et je
pense qu'on peut le faire même pour de
vrai je suis mort voilà première mort un
plaisir voilà ceci était le parfait
exemple de cinq minutes sur dark souls 3
mourir précédé mourir récit et mourir
high five royal ok on y va regardez nous
attend avec sa démarche dégueulasse
[ __ ] on va crever mec c'est bon on a
bu on a vu un avion des biens on esquive
c'est reparti allez cette fois mais qu
on est bien là je vous jure connaît bien
c'est parti on va vraiment analyser je
vais bien fermer ma grande gueule et on
va analyser ses mouvements
bienvenue sur dark souls 3 c'est reparti
la main c'est raté range ta grande main
d'enfant et là j'ai vu tomber dans le
vide
ah ah c'est ça c'est quoi ça valait le
coup spécial du fdp on appelle ça
mais quelle idée de mer devant cette
vidéo par un boss mais quelle idée de de
conte de cons ok on a esquivé l'avant on
est bien voulu coller au cul refait dans
dark souls faut tout le temps collée
aucune aimons c'est très très sexuel
comme je n'en ai bien on est bien à la
crs alors ques est large et pas du tout
j'aime pas du tout est la voie qu une
autre épée c'est super beau mais tous
les ballons franchement on était pas mal
au niveau d'avant-crise
ok c'est ce qu'on va faire je vais
mettre la valse d'amélie dans les
oreilles ok ok ok c'est parti lancement
de la musique la plus stylée du monde
[Musique]
sketches
oui
[Musique]
paul et mick et la bac
ja ja
ciao
pfff tu veux faire tout ce qui est bon à
l'essai marqué mon père factor se
démerdent autour de danser avec le
diable mais bon il est où le feu ya un
feu ne mentez pas voilà ok on allume le
feu les feux c'est l'échec patent de
dark souls je suis en sueur je suis en
sueur ceci est fait on peut placer un
calice ici alors on va le placer mon
gars merci bros aller direction le
prochain boss et on va le défoncer ce
petit fdp salut toi on vient tuer un
boss donc tu vas juste pas nous casser
les couilles à l abri qui l'avait qui
lui fait aucun dégât à moi tu mets de
hockey georges parade en bouche par bush
par mois je mets du beau hockey tient
avec des pointes casgrain sur la tête ça
tu rates et me faire chier à temps là
c'est surya verdugo foule c'est un
ascenseur est bon on prend ce [ __ ]
d'ascenseur j'ai pas il va nous amener
mais on va se mettre bien jardin du roy
et lumineux qu'est ce que c'est que ça
et on commence par te calmes et déjà
direct on l'a eu
on a eu en deux le feu mon gars ça va
exploser petit con alors tu as été remis
en fait je crois que ça c'est une zone
cachée
voilà à quoi ça brasse mais non mais non
mais attends c'est pas possible
d'enchaîner les bosses comme ça avec à
quoi ils ressemblent aux noms mais mort
on met un petit yann tiersen auquel elle
aime ça m'a motivé c'est parti
ok ok ok we go
[Musique]
mais non mais non mais non attends j'ai
fait le mec à guipavas a surtout fait
tout et je meurs comme ça [ __ ]
ok c'est reparti on va te tuer espace de
grenouilles chauloux comme un diplomate
ni pourquoi tu colles à tous oui
surprise de crohn ou lily rapide le coin
hockey dans les jambes dans les cuisses
de grenouilles brunes et vénère du
binaire ou une ultra énervé on fera dans
la rue de grenouilles ont la tis c'est
comment collège n'a plus de potions les
gars plein jour notre live boum boum ou
à [ __ ] ça ça me rend dingue au nom
n'était pas loin c'est pas juste
iron maiden de nouvelles [ __ ] de
puissance les mecs oh [ __ ] vous donner
cette guitare tu cela c'est parti
c'est parti
[Musique]
merde à la fin la [ __ ] je prenne mon à
la fois que battait pas surpris parce
que ça fait six fois que si tu te tue
espèce de gros connard gens flânent mon
épée je me frotte les yeux ces partis
system of a down c'est pour toi
mais [ __ ] de mexes a accusé mon chien
avec ces sauts de grenouille là et je
veux le voir à mort je veux voir
souffrir du coup la prochaine fois que
je vais au grec je veux voir lui sur la
broche et pas de l'avion je veux le voir
lui comme ça on peut aller là à tourner
sur lui-même fils de je pensais pas en
arriver là mais on va devoir faire appel
aux pouvoirs de la banane
les abonnés
[Musique]
faymann a pu s'acheter tout étonné que
cinq fois par jour où nous donnerons
tout assez second à la con j'ai le
tournis je vous jure j'ai le tournis en
apaisée au seros le roi il eut à bazus
ça va être pour me dis que je fasse vous
pouvez en temps les battements de mon
coeur regardez écoutez bien
voilà ça marche et c'est normal les amis
c'est la fin de cette de son talent sous
le choc n'était pas l'aimer si vous en
voulez d'autres c'était hyper simple moi
je retourne jouer à des jeux un peu plus
dur on s'appelle à gala soir et demain
carnot ça alors on s'y retrouve
[Musique]